CNN's Don Lemon makes an awkward on-air
apology for mocking half of his fellow
countrymen as ignorant illiterate rubes
the only problem with Don lemons apology
is that he never actually apologized we
will examine why being a leftist means
never having to say you're sorry then
the fate of impeachment comes down to a
nail-biter on Friday we take a look at
the stakes the Iowa caucuses are just
four days away and finally the mailbag
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Nolt show
[Music]
do we have a lot to get to today my
favorite of course is Don Lemon sorry
I'm not sorry which isn't just about Don
Lemon it's not just about CNN it's about
the whole left wing we'll get to that in
a second first I have got to thank our
friends over at AB sleep if you have
tried everything to get past your
insomnia with little success it is time
for you to try AB and I'd also add if
you sometimes have headaches at night I
get this happens to me a lot trying to
get to sleep with a headache is
virtually impossible AB sleep has the
solution it is a wearable solution fits
over the forehead and gently and
precisely cools the forehead to reduce
those racing thoughts to allow people
who suffer from sleeplessness drift more
comfortably into a deeper more
restorative sleep this is not just some
hokey new idea that was invented by a
millennial or something
AB is clinically shown to help people
with insomnia and other sleeplessness
it's it's shown to reduce those thoughts
those racing thoughts and help you get a
restful night of sleep ABS cooling
calming nature is designed to counteract
the way the mind and body react to
stressful situations it allows you to
reach restorative sleep quicker so that
you can be at peak performance the next
day really really cool stuff have the
energy to do the things you love again
by getting the sleep you need ABS
natural solution has no morning
side-effects and allows you to get back
to your peak performance our listeners
can now try AB risk-free for 60 nights
to confirm that it's the solution you've
been looking for go to try EPP calm /
Knowles t ry e BB dot-com / Knowles try
AB calm / knowles order it today to get
the sleep you need and deserve my
favorite sorry I'm not sorry that I've
ever seen comes from Don Lemon you
remember the other night we saw Don
Lemon on CNN along with two panelists
mocking all conservatives all Trump
voters as idiots ignorant illiterate
rubes they can't find anything on a map
they can't spell they mocked their
southern accents right laughing for
almost 90 seconds so the bigwigs over at
CNN
it would seem leaned on Don Lemon
said man you got to apologize because
our ratings are plummeting now we're
down to six viewers before we were up at
eight viewers and so we were able to
appease the advertisers but now we're
down at six and we're starting to face
some trouble other than everyone at the
airports that we forced to watch our
network so they get Don Lemon to come on
out and give his apology and Don Lemon
you gotta gotta appreciate the cojones
on that guy he goes to give his apology
and never actually apologizes here he is
and one final note that I have for you
because this is personally important to
me to address this okay anyone ask
anyone who knows me they'll tell you I
don't believe in belittling people
belittling anyone for who they are what
they believe or where they're from he
doesn't believe in belittling people not
Don Lemon he would never believe in
belittling people right oh except let's
go back to that clip from three nights
ago and see if you would call that
belittling people he knows that this is
you know an administration defined by
ignorance of the world and so that's
partly him playing to their base and
playing to their audience you know the
the the credulous boomer rube demo that
backs Donald Trump that wants to think
that that Trump's a smart one in there
Oh y'all y'all elitist you and us with
your geography in your maps and your
spelling you know your geography no in
other countries that was good I needed
to spend eighty seconds laughing at half
of the country but I totally totally
would never belittle them what would
give you the idea that Don Lemon would
belittle them then he goes on he sets up
the apology right and with absolutely no
credibility because he's just lying to
your face
did belittle people he did Mach half the
country the other night then he goes on
with a straight face during an interview
on Saturday night one of my guests said
something that made me laugh and while
in the moment I found that joke humorous
and I didn't catch everything that was
said oh there it is
did you see that I hope you caught
everything that was just said he starts
out not by apologizing but by defending
himself says look there was a joke and I
thought that joke was funny
and then the denial and look I didn't
catch everything that was said yes you
did of course you did there was only one
thing that was said the only thing that
was said is that Trump voters are a
bunch of idiots that's actually the
problem with the joke is it was just a
one-note joke Rick Wilson and that other
guy wat watch a hot Ally both said that
Trump voters are idiots and then they
said that same thing over and over in
multiple ways and Don Lemon broke down
laughing for 90 seconds that's though so
you did hear it even if you missed 70
seconds of that joke you did hear the
joke which was that these Trump voters
are complete idiots he denies it he says
nope I didn't hear it anyway never mind
moving on moving on and then he finishes
up his a non-apology apology just to
make this perfectly clear I was laughing
at the joke and not at any group of
people yeah but the joke was the people
what are you talking about you were
laughing at the joke what was the joke
the joke was Trump voters are total
idiots and they talk like this and that
don't read and that don't know geography
that was the whole joke for 80 90
seconds so you were laughing at the joke
and the joke was the people being a
leftist means never having to say that
you're sorry because you can just excuse
yourself all the time and what makes
this so bad for Don Lemon is the the
first segment that he's apologizing for
was insulting people's intelligence and
then the apology is an even greater
insult to people's intelligence because
he's not actually apologizing I'll give
you an example how you don't see this on
the right the premise of this new
podcast that I have with Ted Cruz
verdict with Ted Cruz number one podcast
in the country the whole premise of that
is that people are smarter than you give
them credit for right maybe they don't
speak legalese maybe they don't speak
like politicians but if you take these
highly specialized terms you translate
them into common language people
actually understand what's going on
because people are actually pretty smart
the whole premise of CNN is people are a
bunch of idiots they actually say that
on air and then when they go to
apologize for it they think the viewers
are so stupid that they're gonna believe
a non-apology is an apology give you
another example of this beyond Don Lemon
Elizabeth Warren Elizabeth Warren is now
proposing criminal penalties for
spreading misinformation on the Internet
I'll repeat that Elizabeth Lea wathah
Warren is proposing criminal penalties
for posting misinformation on the
Internet she said I will push for new
laws that impose tough civil and
criminal penalties for knowingly
disseminating this kind of information
just to remind you of who Elizabeth
Warren is here's just a little clip of
her when she was on The Breakfast Club
asked about her racial history it's kind
of like the original Riggs would doze
off a little bit those white women
pretending to be black this is what I
learned from my family yeah yeah well
was it true and you lied and you never
apologized for it Liz Warren you never
apologized for decades of Lies you never
apologized to the Native American whose
job you might have taken in the Academy
you never apologized to the school
administrators that you smeared when you
said that you were fired by a school for
being pregnant when that actually wasn't
true
you never apologized to the voters that
you regularly insult by lying to them
one of Elizabeth's worn one of it
Elizabeth Warren's big problems right
now on the campaign trail she doesn't
learn she doesn't adapt she just keeps
up this same old strategy she keeps on
lying you actually see the same problem
all the way in the United Kingdom in the
brexit vote we'll get to that in a
second we'll get to why leftists never
have to say they're sorry but first even
if you were dutifully checking bank
statements and monitoring your credit
you can still miss threats to your
identity good thing there's life lock
identity theft protection life lock uses
proprietary technology to detect and
alert you to a wide range of potential
identity threats like if your social
security number starts to
for sale on the dark web and that
actually happens and I know you think it
will never happen to you
but when it does happen it's too late
now if you do have an issue involving
identity theft one of life locks
identity restoration specialists will
work to fix it you got to move fast of
course no one can prevent all identity
theft or monitor all transactions and
all businesses but with life lock you
get identity theft protection to help
protect your device's against cyber
threats for up to 25 percent off your
first year go to LifeLock comm slash
knowles KO wles use the service that i
use to protect my identity
LifeLock dot-com / knowles KO wles and
you will get 25% off do it today do not
wait and please do not wait until it's
too late
LifeLock dot-com / knowles you see this
problem this lying this inability to
admit your own mistakes this inability
to adapt from the left even in Great
Britain even in the European Union big
big news coming out of Europe right now
we've been talking about brexit for 3-4
years at this point the UK voted for
brexit to leave the European Union in
2016 for some reason it just hasn't
happened because liberal elites keep
trying to keep them in it's finally
going to happen as of 11:00 p.m.
tomorrow Great Britain will no longer be
a member of the European Union the
Conservative leader Nigel Farage in the
European Union he stood up there he gave
his farewell address he's been pushing
for Britain to leave the European Union
for years and years now they laughed at
him they told him it wouldn't happen he
gave his farewell address and the EU was
so furious about it they actually cut
his microphone take a listen
say this is it the final chapter at the
end of the road a 47 year political
experiment that the British frankly have
never been very happy with it is
globalism against populism and you may
loathe populism but I tell you a funny
thing it's becoming very popular
and it has great benefits no more
financial contributions no more European
Court of Justice
no more Common Fisheries Policy no more
being talked down to no more being
bullied
no more key buffs that I mean I mean
what's not so like I know you're gonna
miss us I know you wanna ban our
national flags but we're gonna wave you
goodbye and we'll look forward in the
future to working with you as sovereign
if you disobey the rules you get cut off
could we please remove the flags oh what
a magnificent moment how this highlights
the difference between the conservative
view and this liberal view never
admitting that you were wrong after so
many obstacles Great Britain finally is
pulling out of the European Union and in
this last act they say look we are
looking forward to working with you
Europe but we are going to work with you
as a sovereign nation and before he can
say nation they cut his microphone and
they cut his microphone because he's
waving the flag of his nation and
several of the other members of the
delegation are actually wearing the flag
on a necktie the Union Jack they send
and when she cuts the microphone the
speaker says put away the flags put away
the flags that's a violation of the
rules hey listen lady if you want to
ensure that the EU completely dissolves
keep telling people to put away their
flags
guess what people like their flags and
they like their countries and that that
has been what these elections whether
it's the United States election whether
it's in Hungary whether it's in Great
Britain whether all over the West right
now there is a resurgence of love of
country of love of nation of these bonds
of loyalty that go beyond this liberal
utopian one-world scheme that they've
been trying to foist on us for decades
you would think that the left could have
some humility
after all of these devastating losses
the brexit loss the donald trump loss
the Boris Johnson loss the losses all
throughout continental Europe but they
don't learn they can't learn they can't
change their minds and it's not as
though you couldn't predict this
Margaret Thatcher one of the great prime
ministers in the history of Britain
predicted all of this years and years
ago in the 1980s Margaret Thatcher
predicted exactly what would happen if
Britain entered into the European Union
its we could have given this speech
three years ago instead of over 30 years
ago here she is the political
consequences can already be glimpsed the
growth of extremist parties back big on
fears about mass immigration and
unemployment offering a real if sorry
unwelcome alternative to the euro
centrist political establishment if in
addition you were to create a
supranational European Federation and
the people could no longer hold their
national parliaments to account
extremism would only grow further you'll
see the growth of extremism you'll see a
lot of worry about mass migration you'll
say guess what that's what defines our
political era and she was right now is
Margaret Thatcher a mind reader are
conservatives just wizards dealing in
the dark arts that they can predict all
these things
no they just maintain a healthy
skepticism about all of these liberal
utopian ideas and guess what it turns
out that they're correct
the big takeaway here from Don Lemon to
brexit to even beyond the left can never
acknowledge that they're wrong because
their vision of progressivism does not
allow it progressivism insists that
there is an end goal there is a utopia
there's this perfect place that we're
getting to and we're getting a little
bit closer all the time but you just got
to follow their path to progress now it
doesn't matter if their path to progress
doesn't work doesn't matter if those
utopian schemes breed human misery
everywhere they're tried the left
doesn't care if their programs work in
practice they care if they work in
theory they care that they're really
consistent all the time they're
consistently wrong but
least they're consistent actually no
where do you see this better then on the
podcaster Joe Rogan's recent endorsement
of Bernie Sanders Joe Rogan came out he
tries not to be too political or too
partisan but he recently came out on his
podcast then his is the number two
podcast in America it's right below the
number one podcast in America verdict
with Ted Cruz a show that I happened to
co-host he came out right away and he
said that he's going to vote for Bernie
Sanders because Bernie Sanders has been
so consistent are you gonna vote for
primary I think I think I'll probably
vote for Bernie him as a human being
when I was hanging out with him yeah I
believe in him I like him I like him a
lot what Bernie stands for is a guy who
look you could you could dig up dirt on
every single human being that's ever
existed if you catch them in their worst
moment and you magnify those moments and
you cut out everything else and you only
display those display those worst
moments that said you can't find very
many with Bernie he's been insanely
consistent his entire life he's
basically been saying the same thing but
for the same thing his whole life and
that in and of itself is a very powerful
structure to operate from Bernie Sanders
has been insanely consistent he's been
insanely consistently wrong he's been
consistently communist he honeymooned in
the Soviet Union there were videos of
him with his shirt off swilling vodka
singing communist folk soon songs in the
Soviet Union with the Rooskies before
the fall of the Berlin Wall
he's been consistently in support of the
worst communist regimes on earth Castro
communists all throughout Latin America
but he has been consistent shows you a
big difference between the left and the
right the left above all values
consistency the worst thing you can be
on the left is a hypocrite this is why
the left all the time
goes so hard after Republican senators
who get caught getting feely with other
men in Airport bathrooms that kind of
thing it's not be coal
the left disapproves of homosexuality
right the left celebrates homosexuality
they should be happy when Republican
senators are getting frisky with other
guys in the airport bathroom it's not
that it's because the Republican
senators are seen to be hypocrites of
Republican senator votes against gay
marriage redefining marriage and then
he's caught with a guy in an airport
bathroom that's the worst thing you can
because you're a hypocrite the chief
sent according to the left is hypocrisy
for the right it's very different the
right values something much more than
consistency the right values actually
being right even if you used to be wrong
now you're right that's a good thing we
would much rather have a moral standard
that we fail to live up to than have no
standards at all if we know as
conservatives we're all flawed and
broken we all fall short of the glory of
God we don't care so much about
consistency if you get it right now we
just elected Donald Trump the the party
of Family Values social conservatives
Christians has elected a thrice-married
lapsed Presbyterian who used to donate
to Democrats who once called himself
very pro-choice
the on the Left they say what hypocrisy
what inconsistency you know what we see
on the right a guy who has matured over
time is now an excellent president and
very conservative and the most pro-life
president we've ever had and extremely
successful I'm pretty glad that we took
a chance on that inconsistent guy I'm
pretty glad that Trump was inconsistent
if he had been consistent he would have
remained a very pro-choice Liberal
Democrat but he didn't he became a
conservative and a very good
conservative president we were right to
choose being right over being consistent
we're seeing this play out in
impeachment too there are reports right
now and I'm getting them every single
night when senator Cruz comes here from
the capital he tells us what's happening
behind closed doors there are reports
that Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell does not have the votes to
block more witnesses in the impeachment
trial
we've already had 17 18 witnesses he's
saying we want to stop it no more
witnesses and this thing it's a total
farce anyway but he doesn't have the
vote
because of those squishy Republican
senators guys like Mitt Romney Susan
Collins Lisa Murkowski those moderates
so right now the president's team says
it's gonna be a nail-biter it's gonna
come down to the wire on Friday or
Saturday there are there are a handful
of Republican senators who don't even
know if they're gonna ask for witnesses
or not a Mitt Romney - he doesn't he has
not said I am going to ask for more
witnesses but he's likewise not agreed
to end this whole thing so in this case
it's extremely annoying is I just really
wish that Romney and the other ones
would get on board realize this is a
total hack impeachment and this thing
and move on and then I can fly back to
it Los Angeles but actually in in
Romney's defense never thought I would
say that this speaks pretty well of
Republicans ok Republicans are not all
just in lockstep we're not all just
falling in line behind the president
blindly we're open to new information
you can't you can't predict exactly what
a Republican or a conservative or a
right winger is going to say if you've
got a hundred conservatives into the
room together not not two of them would
agree on every single thing that's not
true of the left you rarely if ever see
this kind of break among the left you
never see some left-wing or defending
Trump
you never saw some left-wing or really
seriously opposing Obama but you do see
right-wingers criticizing Trump it's
because we've got different ideas
there's a little more intellectual
diversity we're more open to changing
circumstances so what does this mean for
impeachment means John Bolton might
testify and the Democrats will be happy
about that then it means hunter Biden
might testify Democrats will not be
happy about that then more people may
testify then this thing could get
dragged out all the way until March now
conventional wisdom is saying that the
the senators who are running for
president Bernie Sanders Elizabeth
Warren and Amy Klobuchar that they want
to end to this impeachment race so that
they can get back on the campaign trail
but actually for one of them impeachment
has been really really good and
coincidentally it's the one presidential
candidate who's been insanely consistent
it's the one presidential candidate who
just
Joe Rogan's endorsement that would be
Bernie Sanders Bernie Sanders is totally
killing it he's at the top of the polls
why we will find out in a second then we
will get to the mailbag but first I've
got to say goodbye to Facebook and
YouTube and I want to talk about the
pro-life cause well the pro-abortion
activists shot their abortions on
national TV and refer to preborn babies
as parasites pro-lifers have fought back
all of us here at the Daily wire have
spoken out for life and last year been
addressed a crowd of a hundred thousand
people at the March for Life here in
Washington DC our advertisers as a
result were targeted by left-wing
political operatives and several
advertisers pulled their ads from our
shows this is a constant battle to
protect pro-life advocacy from the
forces of abortion live action is
experienced the same thing live action
is one of the most important voices in
the pro-life movement they've helped to
expose Planned Parenthood and other
abortion clinics for the horrific crimes
they commit pro-abortion activists have
targeted live action they've censored
them on social media platforms when they
don't succeed in kicking them off all
together that is why our daily wire.com
members are so important your membership
helps keep our cameras on and our
microphones turned up even when the left
pressures our sponsors that is why from
now until January 31st coming up real
quick
a portion of any daily wire.com
membership will be donated to live
action with promo code live action to
support awareness and education around
the world on this issue this is your
last chance just a few days left to take
advantage of this so join daily wire.com
make your pro-life voice heard before it
is too late we'll be right back with a
lot more
we are five days away I think from the
Iowa caucuses the first big test of the
2020 presidential primary race and
Bernie Sanders the consistent candidate
the man who never said he's sorry he's
at the top of the pack and Joe Biden's
campaign trying to run in the moderate
lane that campaign is falling apart you
can see it falling apart in real-time
the other day Joe Biden was doing an
event in Iowa and he couldn't remember
what year he and Barack Obama got
reelected
[Music]
yeah so that's that's actually the first
part right that's where Joe Biden is now
having to admit his age is a factor in
this campaign he's saying look I'm gonna
need a young VP because I'm an old guy
campaigns that are strong do not need to
rely on their vice president's campaigns
that are strong don't admit that there
is a likelihood that they will not
finish out their term which is what Joe
Biden is admitting and you see it in all
of these memory lapses I mean you saw it
on the debate stage when his eyeball
exploded and his teeth fell out of his
mouth you see it when he loses his
strains of thought which happened a lot
and you see it in Iowa
again just the other day when he
couldn't remember when he got elected if
you are running to be President and your
biggest accomplishment is that you were
the vice president and you can't
remember when you got elected vice
president that's not a great resume
that's not a strong campaign I mean even
just running as the vice president
that's not a that's not even that strong
but if you if you can't remember where
you are probably voters are not gonna
have a lot of faith in you and as a
result of this campaign falling apart a
new candidate has emerged to take this
moderate spot that candidate is New York
billionaire Mike Bloomberg there's a
morning consult poll out of national
voters showing that Mike Bloomberg is
exploding up the charts no he's still
way behind yet remember he started from
nothing and he got into the race late
and he's only half a Democrat he
actually was the Republican mayor of New
York for part of his term then he
switched parties but Bloomberg right now
is at about 12% according to morning
consult closing and unwarranted 14%
still behind Joe Biden who's at 29 and
Bernie Sanders who's at 23 that's a
national poll so it's not in Iowa it's
not in New Hampshire but it's national
overall but Mike Bloomberg is rising
those charts he's got the most momentum
of any candidate whether he can catch up
in time is another story
so Mike Bloomberg is the great hope to
take Joe Biden's spot because Joe
Biden's too old the only problem is Mike
Bloomberg is older than Joe Biden Mike
Bloomberg is nine months older than Joe
Biden so it's very difficult to imagine
the Democrats making a 77 year old male
New York billionaire their nominee for
president also hard to imagine Mike
Bloomberg beating Donald Trump but he
may try to land the moderate lane to
stop Bernie because the Democrats are
very concerned that whatever the
moderate is whether it's Joe Biden or
Mike Bloomberg or even Peabody Judge
they're not going to be able to stop
Bernie don't forget those Democrat
elites had to steal the election from
Bernie in 2016 why why is Bernie Sanders
there's old communist codger who was
around Saint Petersburg when he felt it
was time for a change who knew Karl Marx
personally probably I wouldn't be
surprised
why is he surging in part it's a process
of elimination it's a weak field and
they all have so many flaws that Bernie
Sanders shines in part I think it's
because he's not on the campaign trail
right now I think actually impeachment
is helping him because Bernie Sanders
missing all those gaffes missing all
those radical quotes missing all those
radical new plans Bernie Sanders just
like leftism in general is better in
theory than in reality Bernie Sanders
though is consistent
he has been consistently wrong he has
consistently failed to bring about any
legislation that he's proposed he is
consistently lost and lost Democrats
might learn that lesson before it's too
late I suppose we can only hope all
right let's get to the mailbag I'm
always so late on the mailbag I want to
take a little bit of time today first
question from Joshua even though we know
Democrats won't admit on camera that
Alan Dershowitz has constitutional
arguments swayed them against
impeachment do you think it should have
especially on abuse of power and the
myriad other presidents who have been
accused of such thanks again yes
alan dershowitz one of the presidents
lawyers gave very clear arguments for
why this impeachment is wrong and
unconstitutional and the president
should be acquitted Alan Dershowitz is
not a Republican he's a lifelong
Democrat Alan Dershowitz is not a
conservative he's a lifelong liberal
Alan Dershowitz is not a supporter of
the president he didn't vote for Trump
in 2016 he says he's not gonna vote for
Trump in 2020 but he shows up to the
impeachment to defend the Constitution
what he says is the Democrats have not
accused the president of a crime the
president can only be impeached for a
crime and if you applied the very loose
standard that the Congress is applying
to Donald Trump if you applied that to
other presidents you'd have impeached
George Washington John Adams Thomas
Jefferson all the way up to Abraham
Lincoln all the way up to Wilson and FDR
all the way up to Ronald Reagan and even
beyond that it's it's just not a tenable
idea it's not constitutional those
arguments are unlikely to switch any
votes on the Democratic side maybe I
think Dianne Feinstein the Democrat from
California she sort of signaled that
maybe she would consider a quitting and
then she got so much pushback from the
left that she said she was misunderstood
by the reporter who wrote that so even
she probably not gonna do it the reason
that you're not going to switch any
votes on the Democratic Party or really
on the Republican side in almost all
certainty is because this is a partisan
impeachment it was only Democrats who
impeach the president in the house no
not one single Republican voted to
impeach the president says the first
time that's ever happened we've had
three presidents be impeached in
American history this this third one
president Trump is the first time that
has been strictly partisan and so if you
get a partisan impeachment in the house
you're gonna get a partisan trial in the
Senate and you're gonna get the
Democrats all in lockstep and you get
the Republicans all in lockstep and it's
not even a constitutional issue really
because the Republicans have the Senate
they have the majority and so in all
likelihood President Trump will be
acquitted it's an important
constitutional lesson and hopefully as
this history is written future
legislators will learn from this
partisan impeachments do not
work a lot of the people impeaching the
president right now in the house made
those arguments in the 1990s and that
was not a strictly partisan impeachment
hopefully we will learn it now because
if it's a purely partisan impeachment
then argumentation debate facts evidence
the Constitution none of that matters
it's just a bloodsport between two teams
and we might as well tune the whole
thing out from Tyler dear Michael I live
in Connecticut and I know you spent some
time here I also know you hail from New
York so tell me which pizza is better
New York Pizza or New Haven pizza
New Haven pizza is better it is
objectively New York pizzas wonderful
New Haven pizzas better sally's is the
best in New Haven Pepe is very good too
and bar is also pretty good that's just
a fact pains me because I'm a New Yorker
but facts don't care about people's
feelings and we have to go with the
evidence
New Haven from David hey Michael I got
into an argument with a friend about the
founding fathers they claimed the
founders were dirtbags I strongly
disagree with this after all they
started this great nation however they
did have issues such as slavery and the
fact that Jefferson apparently had an
affair with a black woman who was his
slave by the way what do you think about
the founding fathers do we judge them
too harshly or were they really terrible
people also any books you suggest to
read on them Thanks
the founding fathers were better men
than your friends every single one of
the founding fathers was a much better
man than any of your friends who call
them dirtbags the founding fathers were
better men than you and almost all
certainty and the founding fathers were
better men than me yes they were human
beings and so they had flaws and foibles
yes they lived in history so there were
social evils that existed around them
like slavery as you mentioned but those
men were much much better than we are
we inherited this great nation from them
and we've been messing it up in many
ways especially in our constitutional
order much better men the way that you
can show this to your friends is to just
push history down a little bit so now
we're
over 200 years removed from the founding
generation now what 250 what will people
say about us in 250 years will they call
us dirtbags maybe we're all much less
educated than those founding fathers
we've all accomplished much much less
than the founding fathers and we'll
accomplish much much less than them we
were all much less religious virtually
in all cases few exceptions I suppose
and we live at a time that also is
marked by immense social evil so
founding generation had slavery evil our
generation kills a million babies a year
through abortion a million babies a year
just in America we are killing off a
quarter of the population and by the way
since you bring up the question of
African slavery we're killing off black
babies at a much higher rate than we're
killing off white babies we're killing
off black babies at three times the rate
we're killing off white babies more
black babies are killed in New York then
are born so how are they gonna look on
us
are we dirtbags maybe we are dirtbags
but the founding fathers were not from
Chase hello Michael
my name is chase I know that because
you've sent in the question from Chase
I'm curious to learn who's your favorite
actor my favorite actor that I can see
you know I mean there there are stories
about the great actors in the past like
Garrick or Eleonora Duse or these actors
that really only other actors ever read
about but in terms of the actors that we
could all see and appreciate Brando
Brando is my favorite actor it's an it's
an obvious answer but it's obvious for a
reason in terms of living actors are
recently dead
Philip Seymour Hoffman I think is
magnificent actor was a magnificent
actor Robert Duvall Denzel Washington I
think Jon Voight is a tremendous actor
Kevin Spacey I know I know he's got
political problems now but Kevin Spacey
is an excellent actor Hugh Jackman Edie
Harris Sam Rockwell Bradley Cooper is
very good in terms of my favorite movie
star which is different than act
Tom Cruise there's only one and his name
is Tom Cruise from Thomas hey Michael I
teach middle school students and I get
asked all the time what the differences
between modern Protestants and Catholics
as a history teacher my answer is
usually long-winded what is a simple
explanation for this question thank you
obviously you could go into any number
of things you could go into the our
understanding of Mary the mother of God
you could go into our understanding of
the role of priests and therefore
bishops and the Bishop of Rome who's
also known as the Pope you could go into
all those things but I think the
simplest way to understand it especially
given the fact that there are tens of
thousands of Protestant denominations so
you got to figure out which one you're
talking about the simplest way to
understand it is that the difference is
about our understanding of symbolism
specifically the sacraments and
specifically the Eucharist which is the
sacrament it's the communion wafer it's
the Lord's Supper it's the body and
blood of Christ in the Protestant view
broadly the sacraments are just symbols
so they're totally there you know could
be anything there there's no intrinsic
worth to it it's just you know a little
cracker basically to the Catholic the
communion the Eucharist is the literal
body and blood of Christ and this is
true in so many of the other sacraments
what what the Catholic Church believes
is that the the body and blood of Christ
that the bread is truly Christ's body
and the church is truly Christ's Church
and Christ is truly the divine logic of
the universe so this metaphysical thing
that we call the second person of the
Trinity or the law Gauss the divine
logic of the universe or the Word of God
is is literally this person named Jesus
Christ and they're the same thing and
they come together so for the Catholic
the symbol and the symbolized the thing
that the symbol talks about have to come
together regularly and they do that in
the sacraments they do that in the
church they do that in the priests all
the way up to the Pope
and at to varying degrees the Protestant
churches separate the symbol from the
symbolized and that's been happening for
500 years or so now I know that seems
like maybe a more complicated answer but
I think that actually gets to the heart
of the question and that way you don't
need to get into you know Mary and the
Pope's and the this and that and the
smells and the bills hope that helps
from maderas good day king of trolls and
master of the unwritten word I'm writing
today to regretfully inform you that you
are incorrect when you stated that we
get our right to bear arms from the
Constitution we do not our right to
defend ourselves and our families is an
inalienable right meaning it cannot be
taken from us granted by God not the
Constitution in the Constitution's Bill
of Rights these are rights that are
acknowledged you may even call them
chains placed upon our federal
government that may not ever be broken
when they put regulations upon those
rights they're in violation of the
Constitution in violation of our
god-given rights
I have agree with you you're right the
Constitution acknowledges natural rights
you're right the Constitution puts a
chain on the federal government's a
there are certain things you cannot do
you're right that those rights are
inalienable unalienable in the language
of the Constitution but they can be
taken from you of course they can be
taken from you they're being taken from
us right now and in most countries in
the world for most of history they have
been taken from people the government
can do that we do have a right
abstractly to keep and bear arms but
good luck enforcing that right if you
don't have as good a Constitution as
ours and if you don't have institutions
that respect the Constitution and if you
don't have political stability and if
you don't have people to protect those
rights sure yeah there are there are
natural rights acknowledged by the
Constitution but those rights are not
acknowledged in great many places around
the world and so it's incumbent upon us
not to just rest easy and say oh don't
worry I got my rights from God so that's
all I got to worry about
everything else is fine no we need to
protect those rights we have to fight
for those rights we need to build
institutions that defend those rights or
those rights certainly will be taken
from us from Jacob
greetings Michel what in your opinion is
the greatest television drama of all
time the correct answer to this is
Breaking Bad my favorite television
drama of all time is the Sopranos but
the greatest of all time is Breaking Bad
from Grant High Michael I must apologize
if my question is perhaps a little edgy
and I understand if you can't answer it
on your show oh here we go something I
believe many Christian men that
contemplate and struggle with albeit
secretly and I would appreciate your
perspective we know porn is sinful so
for argument's sake let's remove that
from the equation is masturbation in and
of itself a sin if so how can Christians
overcome it thank you for all you do and
for your constant inspiration great job
on the two new projects sincerely grant
thank you I assume you're talking about
verdict with Ted Cruz the podcast and
the book club at Bray are you yes not
only is porn sinful but masturbation is
a sin it is gravely disordered it's
weird it's creepy and I know that
virtually virtually every guy has done
it at some point in his life and great
probably the vast majority of guys
continue to do it but nevertheless it is
a sin it's not something that you open
the blinds on and you know open up the
window and say hey everybody guess what
I'm about to do you know the people
close their eyes if you ever did that
know it's something that we feel great
shame about and we feel shame for a
reason because it is sinful so how can
you avoid doing it especially if you're
a young man young man have certain urges
that are completely natural the way to
avoid it is to get married and find a
good woman get married and then have
lots of sex
that's the way to do it and this is why
people prolonging getting married until
very late and look everybody does it now
but it's why it's probably not such a
great idea you're not going to get rid
of your sexual urge unless you have the
special gift for celibacy which few of
us do so find a lady get married and
have a good time
from Travis hello Michael I am currently
a college student majoring in political
science and minoring in history as a
conservative in California which jobs
would you suggest I look for after
graduation a couple years I would prefer
to eventually make six figures though my
passions don't seem to match with such a
job many thanks you want me to tell you
what you should do for a living I don't
know I don't know you from Adam oh it's
nice to know what you should do now you
say you want to make six figures alright
yeah it's making six figures it's a very
nice thing I think a lot of people want
to make six figures however the advice I
can give you is that you're getting your
priorities backwards you say that what
you want to do is not conducive to
making six figures I'm not totally sure
about that
one thing I really like doing is not
writing books and I figured out how to
make six figures out of that and and
actually in terms of a long term career
I've never put the money first I have
never cared about look I chose acting in
politics right those are the two to
career paths that pretty much insure
poverty but I've never put the money
first I don't care I've worked for
basically free for long long hours and
it's paid off I don't care I would never
put the money first seek you first the
kingdom of God and all the other
blessings follow it's just do not seek
you first a ton of money because you'll
have a miserable life I have friends who
have done that who chose to just make
money even though they wanted to do
something else and they've either
switched course or they've become
miserable don't do that don't wind up
like that you only have one life do what
you want to do and then work very hard
and figure out a way to make money out
of it but do not sell out your own only
life so that you can make a little bit
more money and buy more stuff the two
don't have to be mutually exclusive but
if you got to pick one don't pick the
Mammon all right that's our show we have
got a lot more to get to we'll just have
to wait on that I am very excited to be
flying to st. Louis tomorrow to give a
speech very quickly and then we will be
back with the number one podcast in
America verdict with Ted Cruz we'll be
taking that through impeachment this
weekend and then we'll be back on this
very show the Michael Noel's show next
week in the meantime I'm Michael Knowles
this is the Michael Noel's show
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Ben Davies director Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey supervising
producers Mathis Glover and Robert
Sterling technical producer Austin
Stephens assistant director pavel
madoski editor and associate producer
danny D'Amico audio mixer robin
Fenderson hair and makeup Jessa alvera
production assistants McKenna Waters and
Ryan love the Michael Noel's show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 on the Matt Walsh show we're
not just discussing politics we're
talking culture faith family all of the
things that are really important to you
so come join the conversation